The other important parameter for an SVM is the C parameter.
So what does C do?
It controls the tradeoff between a smooth decision boundary and
one that classifies all the training points correctly.
So let's suppose our data looks like this.
And just like we saw with gamma, there's a number of different,
completely valid decision boundaries that you can draw in here.
You could draw something that might be very straight, but
it comes at the cost of a few points being misclassified.
You could also draw in something that's considerably more wiggly, but
where you get potentially all of the training points correct.
Of course, the tradeoff of having something that's very intricate,
very complicated like this.
is that chances are it's not going to generalize quite as
well to your test set.
So something that's a little straighter,
a little bit more straightforward may be actually the better choice once you
start looking at the accuracy on your test set.
So here's a quiz for you.
It's a little bit tricky because you'll have to go to the sklearn documentation
or potentially to play around with some code on your own to come up
with the answer.
And the question is let's say you have a large value of C.
Does that mean you're going to get a smooth boundary or
that you'll get more training points correct?
There's going to be a tradeoff.
Again to answer this quiz you're going to want to go to Google or
potentially to the sklearn documentation.
For those of you who are more adventurous or
who like to go directly to the code to figure these things out,
you can certainly play around with some code that will help you visualize this.
One way you can do that is you can go back to the previous lesson,
the Naive Bayes lesson where you were drawing some decision boundaries that you
could actually visualize in the Udacity interpreter.
And instead of running those with Naive Bayes,
of course you can just run them with an SVM and
play around with different values of C and use that to answer the question.
If you do that, just a pro tip, use the rbf kernel, because this is
where you'll actually see a big difference based on the value of C that you use.